comma is getting a promotion the New
York Times noting how the Veep has been
quote taking on a forceful new role in
the 2024 campaign
and it's not force-feeding Joe Biden his
Jello instead Kamala has been traveling
to more States in order to bash Rising
extremism in the Republican party but as
we all know by now the more Kamala gets
out there the more she embarrasses
herself for years we have worked to
expand investment in Community Banks
because you see Community Banks
specialize in providing loans and
financial assistance to small business
owners as the name suggests Community
Banks are in the community
oh that's where they are I couldn't find
them but if you point out any of Kamala
shortcomings prepare to get smeared as a
racist
most people don't know what vice
presidents do and now she is a history
maker she is a woman she is a black
woman and
it's the easy thing to do to say she's
the attack dog go after her she is done
with us the pundit and she's going to
the people who will actually elect her
she's talking about the issues that
women care about abortion I appreciate
it and I think you will see her numbers
start to increase and people will be
accepting her so Harold in The Green
Room you said she's the worst vice
president we've ever had does that make
you a racist
I know I gotta check the tape or not let
me see if I said that D I think we over
racialize things too much we are quick
when regardless of which side people use
that as a way when they want to want to
show you how disappointed they may be
how angry they may be or even uh if they
believe their position is just Superior
to someone else's
the vice president uh is I believe now
trying to
show the things she's been doing and
talk about them in ways that are more
effective and persuasive I have said on
the show we all have
she needs to get to the border the thing
about voting rights that she's been
responsible for she needs to all the
things the president has assigned her to
do or given her as a part of the
portfolio of things to do
uh it's now you don't complain about
those things that's what vice presidents
do in my life I'm 53 I remember vice
vice presidents get tough jobs all the
time that's why you're vice president
you do a good job at it you get a chance
to be president so the over
racialization we hope we refrain a
little bit all of us refrain from from
going there when we want to make a point
yeah it's interesting Katie you the the
accusation of racism racism actually is
because they pointed out her race she
was the least popular choice but they
made her the choice because she was a
black woman if you point that out they
say oh it's because she's a black woman
you're saying that yes because you said
she's a black woman well then you go
back to the 2020 election and Joe Biden
said he was choosing a VP that she would
choose a black woman and then if you
dared to point out that's part of the
reason she was picked you were deemed a
racist which is absurd using race as an
excuse for poor performance is not
helpful in advancing Racial equality in
this country she has not done a good job
it's not Republicans saying it she could
not get through the first votes in the
Democratic primary when she was trying
to run against Joe Biden and yet now
they turn around after three years of
being able to make your own way and be a
Pioneer and have all these
accomplishments they're going back to
the victimhood complex instead of
listing out more of her accomplishments
that she could then use to advance
herself if she chose to run against
maybe future candidates in the
Democratic party even though voters
rejected her around the first time yeah
you know and the thing is Dana this this
new strategy is not a new one this is
old whenever you disagree or anything
they just call you a racist but they get
away with it because the media just
plays along with it if the media just
said you know what maybe you should come
up with something better right she might
end up being better but she's gonna suck
as long as they do this I was wondering
when I read one of the stories yesterday
about the 17th reboot like at what point
is the media going to stop falling for
that story yeah because if you remember
it wasn't Republicans who said she was a
bad candidate it was Democrats she
dropped out in 2019 in December 2019 and
do they presume that the over 50 and 50
in number
Anonymous sources to the New York Times
staffers on that campaign who said she
was an awful candidate are they racist
they worked for her and nobody and they
don't say that right so I I think that
over racializing is a problem but it's
reminded me of like a kid you go to this
um back to school meeting and they're
like your kid just drops a class he
talks too much he's really a prankster
you know things like that and the
parents blame the teacher yeah then the
teachers like uh starts at home and the
calls are coming from inside the house
that's racist when you say it starts at
home that's that's something yeah that's
a dog whistle for racism Jesse since you
invented the dog whistle isn't it
interesting how she's she's going after
the I guess the White supremacists and
the in the Republican party they were
the ones obviously that started the riot
Union Square
so I think she's starting in the right
spot yeah we're gonna see the race card
a lot uh she's on a collision course
with Gavin Newsom either this cycle or
next cycle so it'll be interesting to
see how he navigates that in in that
Minefield on the left Americans
definitely Greg hate uh black history
makers if you look at Barack Obama or
his wife Michelle or or Hillary Clinton
or or I don't know Oprah uh definitely
do not like black history makers in this
country I would argue that you included
Hillary
I'm in terms of women okay I'm including
the gender okay glass shattering but I
would say that she probably gets more
favorable treatment because of her race
and gender and you remember watching
Veep that was also about her spitting
image like evacuous incompetent female
vice president who was also a punchline
she's a punchline Kamala the race has
nothing to do with it it's the
Democratic party who doesn't like Kamala
too much 65 percent of the democratic
base is white 17 is black
and excuse women so is the argument that
black female Democrats are bigoted
against the first black female Democrat
vice president of course not of course
not it's all about her incompetence and
when have Republicans liked a Democrat
Vice President we didn't like Gore we
didn't like Biden we don't like Kamal it
has nothing to do with race there you go
we just don't like them we vice
presidents in general
we don't know what they do all right up
next time to put your pants on America
remote work is officially dead hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now